on va parler des des européennes à venir
ce sera dans 5 mois maintenant est-ce
que Gabriel hatal et sa nomination c'est
la meilleure arme antirassemblement
national pour vous euh non je crois
enfin je je crois pas que les
macronistes soient la meilleure arme
antirassemblement national hein puisque
entre 2017 date de la première élection
d'Emmanuel Macron et 2022 date de la 2e
élection d'Emmanuel Macron le
rassemblement national a progressé en
voie et a progressé en score donc
malheureusement je pense que les
macronistes sont disqualifiés pour être
la meilleure arme pour lutter contre le
rassemblement national par contre oui
bien sûr dans les élections européennes
il y a la nécessité de proposer une
alternative et de faire comprendre ou de
de rendre crédible la possibilité que
pour s'opposer au macronistes on soit
pas obligé d'utiliser le bulletin de
vote du rassemblement national et c'est
la raison pour laquelle moi j'ai défendu
et je continue à défendre l'idée qu'une
liste commune de l'anupess devrait être
de mon point de vue une priorité parce
que c'est ce qui permettrait d'avoir une
alternative crédible et ça par exemple
même que c'est ce serait irresponsable
c'est ce que vous avez dit hier sur BFM
irresponsable que la nupes ne soit pas
en capacité d'avoir une liste commune
aux élections
européennes